[Music]
right so we've got
our basic shiny navbar page and
pretty much any navbar page that you've
seen
you're probably
noticed that
you're constricted to the fact that
each one of these tab links
has to link to content inside of that
page
so we haven't really provided you with a
way to like officially provide another
link here that maybe links to some
external website
um
or
what if you wanted to like have a right
aligned now item that links to like a
login page or something like that
historically there's been no way to do
this officially
with shiny so i've seen people
come up with pretty
crazy hacks to make this possible um
which was part of the motivation for
doing this in the first place
but bslib you know provides this new
api essentially that replaces tab panel
and that bar page and nav bar menu
kind of the basic building blocks that
you may have used to create an app our
page or a tab set panel or something
like that
so with the new interface it's called
instead of tab panel you say nav give it
a title give it some content
there's also a nav item it basically
just takes whatever you give it and
places it directly in that nav heading
so you could do something like provide a
hyperlink to shinee's github page
or wherever you want to provide
a link to
there's actually also ways of using this
to um
include something like
a text input box
which would allow you to implement
something like a search feature in your
shiny app where somebody could type in
like in the nav bar at the top they
could search for something
and then you could wire that up to some
server logic to like show something as
people are typing
something like that
there's also this nav spacer where
it's
kind of like the name suggests it just
adds
spacing in between like one set of nav
items and another set of nav items
so by putting the nav spacer here this
will basically left align
all of this
all of these like the a and the b and
the shiny external link
um and then it will write a line this
nav menu
uh that has other
like you know links to more content
within the page and then another nav
item to link to some other external
content
and this is kind of a fancy
way of reducing duplication for this
particular example where
this nav items function will return a
list of these nav items essentially
so that i can use this
r laying splicing operator to
essentially splice in the list of nav
items
into this navbar page
there's also another argument in navbar
that allows you to
like if you have some content that you
want to show regardless of what
nav item is selected in a navbar page
you can use there's a header and a
footer to say like always show this
content like above or below the other
content that is dependent on whatever
tab
is selected
so i'm using that to also show these
other
functions that can consume a collection
of nav items
called navs tab
nav's pill so these two functions
essentially replace tab set panel
[Music]
for
you know creating that
basic like tab
tab look uh or also with pills
and there's also variants on these
called navs tab card and nav's tab
uh that's kill card
which i'll just show you how these
actually look
so here's the first navs tab here so
this is like you know
the kind of classic tab set panel look
that we're used to seeing everywhere
with the ability to flip through the tab
a and tab b content
i also have this shiny link here which
will take me to shinee's github page
as well as the right aligned menu
with the other external link and some
other content
so
i've taken the same nav items
essentially and placed them inside of
this page nav bar to get the top level a
and b content
so i can flip back and forth here
and then this is the footer content with
those other sort of variants for
rendering a collection of nav items
um so here's
the nav's tab the next pill
i do like this kind of a little bit
generally better than the basic tab set
panel look
in general
but i think part of the reason why like
tab set panel
doesn't always look great is the fact
that there is no padding between this
content here
and the border
and there's also the border doesn't
extend around the content
either so it kind of looks like
there's content sort of floating in
space
and
it's also smashed together
so that's why we've provided this nav's
tab card and nav's pill card
to add some border around all of the
content
and add some padding between that like
top border and the actual content
inside
so
for all sort of functional purposes
these provide the same sort of
functional experience
but this is just
designed in a slightly different way
where it has like a real container
around it
it has
sort of a real header to it
in the sense that it's got this gray
background
holding the tabs and the pills
and you may have seen something like
this already with
i believe in shiny this is called
nav list panel
but i'm now calling it nav's pill list
and there might be like in the future
there might be other different variants
that like render
things in slightly different ways um
but this is kind of like more of like a
sidebar kind of approach where
you can get those navi items stacked
vertically and then the content on the
right so yeah and actually these
functions
are now used by shiny underneath the
hood when you use tab panel or nav bar
page
so now the actual logic for all of that
stuff lives inside of bslib
but we've also like
sort of built out the api
to allow you to do more with it and sort
of
design this functional interface to
allow us to
continue building like more
ways to render navigation items
essentially
[Music]